masi ne serais pas étonné quand vous
passez une interview samedi qu'un des
trois quarts
régis est ce que vous avez déjà arrachés
des pattes de mouche
non j'ai noyé des fourmis
mais j'ai pas arracher les pages des
mouches est ce que ça vous amuse quand
vous voyez quelqu'un dans la rue qui
marche dans une déjection canine
ouais
est-ce que vous tiriez sur le soutien
gorge des filles quand vous étiez petit
au collège village la mesure fille au
collège des grands mais
est-ce que vous aimiez pincer les fesses
des filles oui
oui
créditeurs j'adore et dont les tétons
est-ce que là on est aux fesses il ya
une progression et qui réalisera les
tétons aussi
du bas est ce que vous avez déjà eu
envie de mettre le feu à quelque chose
non c'est non non vous soyez bien
j'étais les cailloux sur les pigeons
ou des pigeons sur les cailloux ça va
chauffer
non j'aime pas des pigeons mais je leur
jette pas de cailloux bombesque pardon à
ce que les payons les bilans payent trop
d'impôts
[Rires]
oui un petit à un hommage
en passant il n'oublie jamais tu
t'y chevalier malade peut le remplacer
un mois chez paul yvon chevalier cheval
n ont pas de polyvalente devant florent
pagny
est ce que vous êtes jarry en voyant une
personne tombée dans la rue non au nom
sony annonce yeux serait décédé
[Rires]
c'est drôle desserrez c'est drôle
jamais rire parce que c'est drôle est ce
que vous êtes déjà caressé avec un
couteau
et deux couteaux
est-ce que vous avez déjà caressé un
couteau comme un manchois oui tout le
monde non ouais est-ce que vos yeux
brillent devant une opération de
chirurgie est ce que je suis je
remettrai plus grand qu'un
jeu sur france 2 j'ai jamais assisté une
opération de chirurgie vérifiera s'il
vous plaît pas mélanger le blanc et les
couleurs qu'on fait là et c'est
pourquoi il faut pas
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu